[موسيقى]
اشترك
افتح ما تفعله ، ولا تتناول الحلوى في اسطنبول
أتساءل عما إذا كان مجتمع قيمة المشتري أنا
الفضة ، لا تزال عالقة هناك ، لا يزال الاستشهاد
هل تريدها تانيا؟ هيا ، أرسل رسالة
بقدر تركيا ولكن لماذا
دخل الشركة والأسرة
أفضل عام عسكري القبلة دعونا رجال الاطفاء
لا تتردد في رؤية المزيد من الفن
ثقيل على الفرع
أذربيجان كلاهما
شركة تركيا
[موسيقى]
هل يوجد
هذه
هل كان لسعيد جثة مغطاة بالكفار؟
ولكن أي نوع من الحياة هو الموت الثقيل
تعال والدة الله ، ابحث عنها ، دعها تحدث
دعنا نحصل على شيري الكبير
للمتعة
ب - مناسبا المظهر
ل
بالطبع بايكار هي شركة عائلية قديمة
اوزدمير بيرقدار
تأسست عام 1985 ولديها درجة عالية في صناعة السيارات
تصنع بدقة 2000s
في بداية السنين
إنها طائرتى بدون طيار فوق هذه المنطقة
في منطقة الأدوات
ومساعد باحث في الخارج
جانب
أنا أعمل عليه لأول مرة في العالم
تشكيل 300 طائرة بدون طيار
اعمل بدلا من الجامعة o
في ولاية بنسلفانيا بعد ذلك
في ذلك الوقت بمنحة من هناك.
أخي والدي يدخل أعمالنا هنا
التحول للعمل في الميدان
لذلك لمبادرة الأسرة حتى والدتي
إنه يعمل لنا أيضًا ومن أصغرهم
أول سيارة ميني في تركيا
تطوير المركبة الجوية غير المأهولة
عندما تقول الحرب البشرية المقدرة ، مثل هذه صغيرة
إنها طائرة ولكن ما يهم حقًا هو ذلك
نظام الدماغ الطائر المعروف أيضا باسم الطيار الآلي
نظام للطيران تلقائيا.
البرمجيات والكهرباء التي توفرها
حاسمة عند تطوير هذه
التكنولوجيا في هذا العالم في ذلك الوقت
ابق صغيرا كما هي اليوم فهي غير موجودة
بمعنى آخر ، هذه المنطقة معروفة جيدًا في العالم.
ليس موضوع البحث أكثر
بدءًا من الأصغر إلى ستة كيلوغرامات
البداية وأول إنسان في تركيا
ذلك اليوم ، بمعنى من المعاني ، من خلال شن الحرب
لتكنولوجيا المستقبل
تأسست بايكال من خلال العمل ولا تزال حتى اليوم.
هذا كل شيء بدءًا من ستة كيلوغرامات
عشرين سنة تمتد ستة أطنان
يعمل دائما من أجل المستقبل في قصته
من خلال التركيز على مجالات المستقبل
يستمر
هل هذه السيارة Metek كثير الكلام؟ هل هي مسطحة؟
علم أساس اليرقة من أي وقت مضى أبي العمل أ
الحاج عم السجادة
نعم بالطبع الطيران شغف
والدي هو أيضا طيار هاو.
عندما كان طفلاً صغيرًا ، كان طيارًا هاوًا في ذلك الوقت
التحق بالدورة التجريبية واصطحبني معه.
أخذني للسيطرة على الطائرة بأكملها
قوائم
لقد حفظتها منذ الصغر
أنا أتعامل مع كلا الطرازين و a
عندما تصعد على متن طائرة لأول مرة ،
من طائرة ذات محرك واحد مع مثل هذه المراوح
نتحدث عنه عندما نطير
عندما يقطع عن الأرض يكون على الأرض مرة أخرى
أنت تعيش الآن بشغف حياتك
بمعنى ما
كان يحلم دائمًا بأن يكون طيارًا
لكن والدي مهندس والدتي أيضًا
اقتصاد شعرين
أنا أيضًا ، بالطبع هذا نوع من الاستعداد
من الهندسة إلى الفيزياء إلى الرياضيات إلى الحقول
موجودة منذ الطفولة ولكن الطيران
ابي
نموذج طائرة نموذجية
طيار من الخارج وكذلك في العمل
كان مدرسًا عندما ذهب إلى الدورة.
بالطيران على متن الطائرة مع المعلم
أستطيع أن أقول أنها بدأت.
كان الحدث لحظة Berat act elitaş
أقدم رسالة في الأسفل أنني قمت بتوصيل الموقد
بناء hd50 لكن
أنت تعرف حضارتنا في الواقع
التأسيس عندما تنظر إلى العلم الإيجابي
عصر الحضارات
تخصص في القرآن بما في ذلك التخصصات
هل قام المسلم بتربية هذه الحضارة؟
من ابن سينا ​​إلى حرزمي إلى أولوبي
دوائر ابن الهيثم
حتى أنا خبير
أنا خبير في الروبوتات في فرع القرآن.
في الحقل
كنت مثقفة ومتعلمة في القرآن
حتى عالم مسلم
عالم يدعى سيزري عاش في الجزيرة
لكن هذه الأولوية نحن
عندما يأتي عصر جديد
قال دار الحكمة تأسست في بغداد الشهيرة
منهجية علمية بمعنى ما في العالم
بعد إعادة إضفاء الطابع الرسمي
حضارتنا هي هذه في العلم والتقنية.
للأسف بعد 15 16 17 قرن
نرى أن الرابطة العضوية مكسورة
E خائف قليلا لا نستطيع
نرى أن الشعور قد استقر أيضًا
تخيل الآن أنك في العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين.
في المئة في صناعة الدفاع التركية
بلد يستقبل 85 منهم من الخارج
في الموقف وأنت تقول القليل جدًا في العالم
سأعمل على موضوع معروف
أنت تقول وهذه هي قضية التكنولوجيا.
ربما إذا كان الموضوع الذي نتحدث عنه هو كباب
ليس كذلك ، ولكن بالفعل في التكنولوجيا و
الثقة في موضوع علمي
عدم وجود مستقبل
تقول شيئًا وهميًا تقوله
سنعمل في هذا المجال
سنكون القائد ، هذا هو الشخص.
عندما لا يكون هناك مثال مشابه من قبلهم
يبدو من المستحيل جدا بالنسبة للبعض.
لذلك يبدو الأمر سخيفًا جدًا
غادر حتى بالقرب منك
ضع في اعتبارك ذلك في صناعة الدفاع
سوف تعمل هذه المصالح الدولة
البيروقراطية ، دعهم يذهبون
الأشخاص المقربون منك متزوجون هنا بالفعل
منذ الشعور بأننا لا نستطيع
العقبة الكبيرة هي في الواقع أن هذا في أذهاننا.
عقبة ، أي العيش مع الثقافة
العقبة في نموذجنا مرة واحدة
بادئ ذي بدء ، لا توجد طريقة
من الضروري بمجرد سماعها
أبدا ولا تدخل السباق
حتى لو كنت تؤمن وأرضية المنافسة
ليس هذا هو أكبر عقبة
أستطيع أن أقول أكثر تحديدا
جانب
يمكنني أن أشرح بالأمثلة ، لكني أعتقد ذلك أكثر
عقبة كبيرة لا يمكننا تحقيق نجاحي
بمعنى الأقمار الصناعية هذه المجالات من التكنولوجيا نحن
هذا هو الشيء الحقيقي مع الشعور بأنه لا يمكنك التحسن
لقد تغيرت تركيا في كل مكان
بدءًا من 10515 مساهمة محلية ، اليوم
ثمانون بالمائة في صناعة الدفاع التركية
الأكبر في العالم
مركبة جوية بدون طيار
قامت SV بتحسين أدواتها بشكل كبير
ssa منفصلة عن النفس هذا كل شيء
القصة هي أيضا الشيء الرئيسي الذي تغير
إنه اسمي ، يمكننا فعل ذلك
هل نفعل الأفضل في العالم
هو شعور
احبك لا تسمح ليكم مبارك
قماش العلم
امرأة باردة
كانسو ممتلئ
احصل عليه
هذا BİM هو تقريبا shoravi
حسنًا بالطبع أول شيء شعرنا به
منذ اليوم الأول عشنا أصغر عمر
عشنا حتى عندما بنينا أصغر طائرة
أول إنسان في تركيا موجود عندما نوجد
كان مؤلمًا ، بحجم نموذج طائرة
ما كانت أول سيارة له في تركيا
ماذا فعلنا للنظام التجريبي؟
كان الشيء المهم أنه كان لديه واحدة أيضًا
كان هناك جهاز كمبيوتر 6 كيلوغرامات على متن الطائرة التالية
طلب
بنينا المروحية بدون طيار ثم 650
أصبح كيلو بايراكتار tb2 مشهورًا جدًا
الآن ، كان أكينجي الذي يبلغ وزنه 6 أطنان موجودًا منذ اليوم الأول.
نشعر في كل هذا النضال
الشعور الذي نشعر به هو أيضًا هذه الرحلة الأولى
يمكن اختبارها عند محاولة ناجحة
ربما لأنه كان هناك دائمًا شعور بالامتنان
من أعطانا كل هذه الاحتمالات
نحمد ربنا إلى ما لا نهاية.
احصل على كل شيء
إذا فكرنا في الأمر ، فهذا بلدنا
معظم الدراسات المرتبطة في التاريخ
لسوء الحظ ، كثير من أولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك
في الماضي
تقنيًا في بعض الأحيان
كان فانيرو في بعض الأحيان بيروقراطيًا
كانت هناك كل أنواع العقبات
في بعض الأحيان كانت هناك مكائد
كل ما تبذلونه يا رفاق تفعل أفضل ما لديكم
تحاول أن تفعل ذلك بكل قوتك
ها نحن الاثنان يجب أن نعبرهما الآن
عددنا قريب من عدد أكبر من ملم
هناك من لا يعرف هذا ولكن عند صنع الطائرة الأولى
كنا 15 كنا عشرة كنا في العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين
في البداية ثم حتى الصباح
كنا نعمل الآن قمنا بتغيير طائرتنا
خاصة في العمل من وقت لآخر أثناء التطوير
نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا أثناء تحضير الداخل.
نحن نبذل كل جهد وبالطبع
كل الأجزاء التي يمكنك القيام بها
بعد الانتهاء ، والباقي على الله
بقيت مع الآية كلها ، أي كل شيء.
قبل أن يذهب قبل أن ينسكب
من يحكم الكون هو لنا بمعنى ما
أعظم شعور عشناه على الإطلاق
خاصة بعد كل هذا النجاح الحمد لله
يوجد مهندس ايضا
ما فعله بالإنسانية بوطنه
أن تكون قادرًا على خدمة الأعمال التجارية أمر مفيد
لتتمكن من رؤية ذلك في المهندس
tavegyl في الحياة أعظم سلام روحي
أستطيع أن أقول أن هذه هي الجائزة الكبرى ، هذا هو الشاعر الملك.
الله ولكن حقًا فضولي جدًا أيضًا
أسفل
مشى حنفي أفجي أ
وقد تم تأديب هذا تعال ناقص
شركة fiav تبيع الكهرباء لتقنية التغصنات
الاتحاد الأوروبي دعنا تركيا
استجابة
[موسيقى]
الأخت الكبيرة
اليس كذلك
هذا العام أدرج رأسي القديم بولو في هذا المجال
اقرأ قصة ديلا تفضل المنتجع التركي
Halil فكرة إطفاء مريحة للإنتاج
كنت استراتيجية ولكن من الأفضل أن تذهب بعيدا
إذا كان الأمر كذلك ، انظر إلى العالم المؤلم
يصبح هدفنا صارم ما هي شجرة التنوب الحقيقية
لابرادور haddin Lite 17 تركيا
ولي أمر عسكري مختلط ياسين ورقية
لكن الحفرة أليف ، الرأس قليلا
أصلية Bursa 60 ذات سريرين
ليس والده نورا أحمد
على محمل الجد هذا كل شيء ولكن جراحة Fi هي عليه
هو
حسنًا ، أدِر رأسك فورًا ، المهندس في تركيا
اوزمير براك دال نيتك في الصورة
تكلفة فيلم Elentra المنفصلة عن موسى
لا تكذب ، نكتة و
تركيا الخيالية
[موسيقى]
والله
أليس هو
[موسيقى]
ماذا
هناك رمل ، أوه ، الفستان ، اذهب سلجوق
أبلغ رب التفاح وعازب
جثة شقيق سوات أن هذه الساحرة معروضة للبيع
هذا بيردال ، هيا أنت اللغة الأم
ليس له حق
حسنًا بالطبع نحن أول تركيا بدون طيار
صنع الطائرات الصغيرة Bayraktar ihi
بالطبع ، بدأنا بفريق صغير يا أبي.
أخي على الحصان وأمي معنا.
لقد كان معًا وكان عددهم 5-6 أشخاص
لدي فريق صغير من 15 شخصًا في المجموع.
كنت أيضًا مساعد باحث في ذلك الوقت.
اسطنبول التقنية بالخارج
بعد أن أنهيت دراستي الجامعية
الجامعة في ولاية بنسلفانيا ، ومن هناك إلى بورصة
هل جعلت على درجة الماجستير لذلك
في هذه الفترة ، نحن في بايكار ولن نرى بايكال مرة أخرى.
كانت تنتج أجزاء الماكينة مسبقًا و
شركة تصنع قطع غيار الآلات الدقيقة
لتكون من لحظة إليف في ذلك الوقت
هذه تكنولوجيا الحرب البشرية
بدأنا في تطوير تخصصي
ابتسامتهم التلقائية في الميدان
الأنظمة التي تجعلها ذكية
أعني ، جسدها يشبه نموذج طائرة بمعنى ما.
لكن بالطبع تركيا وأكثر دول العالم
لكنه لم يكن يعرف في ذلك الوقت مثل هذا
طائرة يمكنها الطيران بتقنية الروبوت
كان هناك القليل جدًا من المعرفة حول كيفية القيام بذلك في العالم
فقط في المعامل البحثية
في الدراسات التي أجريت ، كانت هذه
لحظة جديدة على وشك أن تبدأ
بدأنا العمل بالطبع كما قلت
النقطة الأكثر أهمية هنا هي أن هذه البرامج و
أفضل لتصميم الإلكترونيات
في الواقع أنا أفعل التصميم الفعلي و
أكثر من مجرد إنتاج هذا التصميم بنفسك
تصميم من الخارج
دائما تعتمد على الخارج
بدأ بشعاره وخطوته
اسمي
عمل ضده برأس ماله الخاص
بالطبع ، هل نيتي مسلحة أولاً؟
عندما سلمنا لقواته هو
كما قلت في ذلك الوقت ، كل الدفاع
مثل هذه الرؤية للصناعة
متطور لكننا تماما
تقريبا بالكامل من 2000s.
لقد تم ربطه بالخارج في البداية ، هذا هو
الصبر مطلوب بمعنى ما
من الضروري دراسة المستقبل
في السباق ، أي في سباقات ذلك اليوم ، في العالم
ربما في سباقات التكنولوجيا الحالية
لا يمكنك أن تكون ناجحا ولكن
تدرس المستقبل
التكنولوجيا ، حتى لتكون رائدة في العالم
الهدف ، كما تعلمون ، بايكار فعل ذلك أيضًا
لذلك اليوم لم يكن السباق غدًا
عملية خطوة بخطوة من خلال محاولة السباق
بعد المدافع البشري بعد بيرقدار
طائرة هليكوبتر بدون طيار بعد عام 2007
ليس مشروع كوبتر صغير في السنوات
تلقائيا قادرة على الطيران
لقد سألت ميني. رحلة قصيرة الآن.
لها مدى وتبقى في الهواء لمدة ساعة.
تضغط على زر ، تنفجر
انتقل إلى النقطة التي وصلت إليها والاستكشاف المباشر
و 15 كيلومترا
يمكن أن يذهب ، ولكن بمعنى من خلال القيام بذلك
أول قطعة مثل أصغر قطعة من الليغو
هذا الكمبيوتر لديه واحد
يوجد جهاز كمبيوتر فيه جسم الطائرة
هناك أجزاء أخرى ، فكر في الأمر
40 على Bayraktar TV عند التكبير
يوجد جهاز كمبيوتر هناك في عام 2010
بدأنا العمل في عام 2014 بالطبع
بيرقدار لماذا هي ناجحة جدا؟
Bayraktar في tb2
بدأ البرنامج بدأ البرنامج
من قبل وكيل وزارة صناعة الدفاع
مسلح لأول مرة عام 2014
دخل جرد القوة ، وهو
يمكن أن تحارب الإرهاب
كان ناجحًا جدًا في عملياته و
خاصة في العمليات بالخارج.
ناجح جدا وفي جميع انحاء العالم
أصبح Oo ناجحًا
ثم في عام 2016 Biz Akıncı بدون طيار
بدأنا العمل على الطائرة
منصة أكبر بحيث يمكنك أيضًا 40
إذا كانت هناك أجهزة كمبيوتر ، فإن Bayraktar موجود على TV2.
هل لديه 300 جهاز كمبيوتر؟
مقياس بالمعنى الذي تعرف أنك تفعله
تذهب من خلال وضع العمل ودائمًا عليه
وبهذه الطريقة بالطبع من ناحية
أول اختلاف لنا باسم Baykar
مرحبا التكنولوجيا من اليوم الأول الآن
إنه شيء هش للغاية لذا فأنت تأخذه
احصل على هاتفك المحمول المتقدم في ثوانٍ
خذها إلى ساحة المعركة
ولكن إذا لم يكن لديك الجهاز لشحنه أو
لن يعمل في البرد بل لليمين
سيكون عبئا على ظهرك ، هذا هو الأخ الأكبر على أي حال
لذلك أنت تحمل عاليا
التكنولوجيا لمواءمة تلك الظروف
يجب أن يأتي وبسرعة
يجب أن تتكيف معنا من اليوم الأول.
من بلدي أيضا معظم المهندسين
حياتنا مع أصدقائي
يمكننا القول أنها مرت في الميدان أكثر من ذلك
نحن نذهب بسرعة إلى ساحة المعركة
من أجل التكيف
التكنولوجيا لتعويض النقص
للحفاظ على الأفضل في العالم
كتغذية مرتدة من ذلك اليوم ، أي فعلًا
بالبقاء الأسرع على أساس محرم
طريق
برمجياتهم ، أجهزتهم الإلكترونية ، بالعربية.
للقيام بالمهمة الأكثر تقدمًا
لقد تم إنفاقه في العمل ، لذا فإن القليل من Baykal
مختلف وهذا أيضا بالنسبة لنا في ساحة المعركة
لقد كنا والتين ليدينا سيت لان كيم
Cille ليست محلية إذا تم إنشاء الخريطة
كم عدد الألسنة
نعم ، الآن ماذا عن Bayraktar Mini؟
جده ، شقيق ساهر ، المدينة التي نعم ، هيا
نعم ، بركات ، والد الجميع ، آتا
الماء هو الأصغر ولكن
إنَّهُ هو الأكثر حكمةً
الإنسان بعد تلميذنا الأول
هليكوبتر Manzikert هليكوبتر بشرية
للأسف هذا المشروع
أجهض حظره معفى آتا
يعني اليس مصطفى هيا؟
يتم رميها ليلا ونهارا تطير في الليل
يستطيع أن يرى ، يرى حرارة 15 كيلومترًا
في الهواء لمدة ساعة في ذلك الوقت
يمكنه البقاء هكذا في حقيبته
يمكن نقلها وتخيلوا ان الجندي
تركيا ، بالطبع ، مع إرهاب شديد للغاية
عاش فترة نضال أربعين سنة.
وهذه البنادق بشرية
حتى يأتي Bayraktar tb2
استمرت حتى قبل تركيا
كانت هذه الطائرة بدون طيار تشتري من إسرائيل
بدأنا من المروحة على الأدوات بالطبع
أصغرهم يقوم بمراقبة قصيرة المدى
لكنك ستذهب يومًا ما
اذهب إلى المكان في 10 دقائق في 15 دقيقة وعيش
يمكن نقل الصورة du ثم الخطوة
خطوة بخطوة قمنا بتطوير المروحية
المدى القصير 15-20 في طائرة هليكوبتر
يمكنه أن يقطع كيلومترات
ترى خلفك
مركبة جوية بدون طيار Bayraktar tb1
Bayraktar ، النموذج الأولي الذي يمكننا تسميته
tb2 نينو
هذا العرض التوضيحي لتقنية الحافلة كافٍ
ديمقراطي متماسك هكذا عندما طار لأول مرة
تم الخروج تلقائيًا من الحظيرة
ذهب إلى المدرج نهضت تلقائيًا ونزلت
في هذه الفترة تركيا الخارجية
لذلك أنا أتحدث عن عام 2009 في الخارج
تقلع الطائرات المستأجرة تلقائيًا
لذلك لا يمكنه حتى النزول
طيارين إسرائيل طيارين تركيا يد
ينزلون ويرفعون بجهاز التحكم عن بعد
طائراتهم حتى ذلك الحين
تلقائيًا مع البرنامج الذي قمنا بتطويره.
بطريقة ما نهض وعرف مرة أخرى
بدون طيار في ذلك الوقت
كانت أدواته متقدمة على تقنيته بالطبع.
لم يتم وضع هذا العمل في الإنتاج
عندما كان هذا المشروع ناجحًا ، كانت صناعة الدفاع
الرئاسة نحن اثنان
أكثر قليلاً في العام من عام 2012
تخضع لفترة
وحدثت بعض المشاكل البيروقراطية
حسنًا ، كانت هناك عقبات مختلفة ، لكن
على أي حال ، في النهاية
من 2012 إلى 2014 نحن
قمنا بتطوير Bayraktar tb2 Bayraktar
على رأس TEB وهو موجود في العالم الآن
أشهر طائرة بدون طيار في فئتها
أصبح بايكال وسيطًا مع 16 دولة اليوم.
لطيفة تعمل في مجال العقارات في ذهن التمويل
مع الحياة
ديفاني لتشعر بما أنت
طبعا بيرقدار طبي وهؤلاء بشر.
الفصل الذي يقاتله هو الفصل الذي يكون دائمًا أكثر
يعني أن الطبقة الكبيرة هي القمة
إنه لا يأتي أيضًا ، لذلك أحيانًا الصغار أيضًا
يمكن أن يكون بارعا جدا مجرد استخدام
أشكالها مختلفة Bayraktar tb2
بمدى يصل إلى مئات الكيلومترات
يمكن أن يبقى في الهواء لمدة 27 ساعة
ويمكن أن تحمل حمولة تصل إلى 130 كيلوغراماً.
قد تكون الكاميرا جيدة أيضًا.
يمكن أيضًا أن تكون الحصائر عبارة عن حصائر ذكية
هذه حساسة للغاية ويمكن أن تكون أ
إذا كان الإنسان هناك ألم وغير ذلك
بالطبع الحرب الإلكترونية الأكثر تعقيدًا
حاليا في ساحة المعركة في
معقدة للغاية لمنع هذه الطائرات
أنظمة مختلفة ودفاع جوي
لديها أنظمة حرب إلكترونية
لديهم أنظمة متقدمة جدًا ضدهم
الخوارزميات مع البرامج
عظم
طائرة بدون طيار مغاربية متقدمة
لكن المهاجم أكبر منه
يمكن لبايراكتار القيام بمهام استراتيجية
مطالبة عملية الحد الأقصى للارتفاع tb2
25 ألف فذ 27000 قدم
نعم ارتفاع تركيا قمنا بتطويرها أولاً
كما قلت ، حطم الرقم القياسي في 27 ساعة.
حتى تتمكن من البقاء في الهواء
طويلة جدًا عندما تفكر في الطائرات العادية
لفترة من الوقت لأن هذا هو كيف يستكشف
هؤلاء هم أكثر
وهي عملية طويلة جدًا و
تقرر صورة العيش قرار آخر
يحيل أجهزة الإرسال ، بطبيعة الحال ، على سبيل الواجب
سيطلق مقر SD الذخائر
إنتاج العلم الذي أعطيته لكم بحساسية شديدة
بيرقدار
لا تستطيع زيوت tb2 Mini فعل ذلك.
يلعق مصغرة فقط قصيرة المدى القصير
إنهم يستكشفون لفترة من الوقت أكينجي بالطبع
da a حرف TV 2's deyu class
هو موهوب أكثر بكثير
والاستراتيجية
أداء المهام حتى رحلة بحرية
يمكن أن يحمل الهواء صواريخ
الاشتباك بالمناسبة ، أي طائرات أخرى
قادر على الهجوم
سيكون وحمل حتى نهاية عام ونصف
إذن هذه هي الحمولة التي نحملها
لأن الطائرة يمكن أن تحمل
رصيف محبوك ومرتفع
لكنها لا تبقى في الهواء لفترة طويلة
يمكن أن تستمر لمدة تصل إلى 25 ساعة والمهمة
حسب حمولتها
تختلف مدة الإقامة هذه و
تلفزيون Bayraktar حيث أنه يتحكم بالأقمار الصناعية
2 قد سمع نسخة السيطرة عليه
لذا فإن مداها في أي مكان في العالم.
قادرة على العمل في مكان واحد
الآن يمكنك التفكير في FIFA
بالمناسبة ، حساب جيد 0 هنا
ساعة
طبعا وفقا لهذه الطائرات العادية ، هذا الإنسان
حروبهم أقل وضوحا على الرادار ولكن
كلاهما في معركة أذربيجان كاراباخ
أيضا
في عطل
خاصة في المقدمة أننا نحارب الإنسان
كلا ضد الدبابات و
ضد أنظمة الدفاع الجوي المتقدمة
أنه حقق نجاحًا كبيرًا
أحد أهم الجوانب هو ذلك
البرنامج الذي نطوره وبالطبع
كما أن كونك غير مأهول له تأثير كبير.
العديد من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني في الأشخاص في بعض الأحيان هذا خطر
من المستحيل تحقيق نجاح كبير
لتظهر
ضد هذه الرادارات ، الطائرات العادية
أستطيع أن أقول أنه يبدو أقل من
ولكن بالتأكيد نأمل الجمهور الجاد لكم
الرسالة التي أصبحت تركيا One Mana كرتون
الجدول العلم دولفين
الاستفادة من البريد الإلكتروني الأمني
ش هذا سؤال مهم جدا تركيا هذا
في الحقل
ما يقرب من 185 في صناعة الدفاع بأكملها
كما قلت ، تعتمد على الخارج ، 2000
نفذت من بداية
إنه صراع طويل الأمد
تركيا في صناعة الدفاع
حتى اليوم سبب الاستقلال
من أجل التحدث عن الرخاء و
أنت تعرفه في جميع أنحاء العالم
استحوذت التكنولوجيا على الفور على رياح التحول الكبيرة.
كما يجلب
عظيم أن تكون أعظم مزدهر
اقتصادي
يُنظر إليه على أنه طريقة للكسب
عندما تنظر إلى أكبر الاقتصادات
عالية بالضرورة
قادرة على تطوير التكنولوجيا
ترى ذلك حتى من الإنتاج
الأهم من ذلك ، هذه التكنولوجيا هي التصميم
ترى ذلك لذا فكر في أ
هواتفنا المحمولة نحن جميعًا تقريبًا
يتم القيام به في الداخل ، ولكن القيمة المضافة الحقيقية
أين تقيم في البلدان التي صممتها
يبقى إذا كان الهاتف نفسه 100 ليرة
ربما فقط لانتاج 5 ليرات
95 ليرة باقية على جانب المنتج
يبقى في جانب المصمم مرة واحدة
النقطة المهمة هي أن هذه الأنظمة هي الأكبر
مع المكونات الحاسمة للقيمة المضافة
أن نصمم معًا بالطبع هذا
من الجانب
عندما تقول هذه الصناعة الدفاعية ، الدفاع
قال في صناعة إذا كنت تفكر
بالتأكيد هذا يحدث في الخارج
السيطرة أو
خال تماما لك
لديك فرصة لاستخدام
لذلك فهو بالتأكيد التصميم الخاص بك.
ويجب أن يكون لدينا إنتاج خاصة
عندما نقول صناعة الدفاع ، مثل
أنت تواجه المعادلة
في الوقت الحالي بيرقدار بالطبع كل شيء
جميع التصاميم الهامة خاصة بنا
المكونات هي أيضا محليا
سواء أنفسنا أو المقاولين من الباطن.
متاح منا
نظام محسن
في معركة أذربيجان ، كان يعمل منذ سنوات
تركيا مرتبطة بالفعل بهذه الأنظمة
هناك حالات حظر ، ولكن هذا هو الحال في الصحافة.
أتت زخرفة متعلقة بالكاميرات ونحن
بالطبع كل ما يريده المستخدم في ذلك الوقت
كنا نضع الكاميرا ونعطيها ، لكن المحلية
لكن هذه المرة تم تطويرها بواسطة ASELSAN
فكر في الأمر على أنه نظام كاميرا
تحميل الطائرة للقيام بهذه المهمة
توفير
تركيا مع موطنها الأصلي أسميها التكنولوجيا
تتكيف منذ 2000s ، مثل
عندما يحاول أسيلسان
واصلنا مع كاميرته إلى جانب ذلك
إذا كنت تفكر في الذخيرة
بالطبع ، أنت تزود من الخارج
شبه مستحيل صواريخ
الخيول التي طورتها منذ البداية
لدينا بالفعل طائرات بدون طيار.
يتم استخدامه ، لذلك يمكننا تسميته حرجًا
أي مكون هو أيضا بلدنا في الخارج
نحن لسنا مدمنين ماذا يعني ذلك إذا
غير حرج حتى لو لم يعط
لمكون من مورد محلي
نستطيع أو بالفعل
ماذا لو وسادة الفرامل من الاطارات
هنا كل مئات الآلاف من الأسطر فيه
إنتاجنا الخاص بالكامل حتى البرنامج
إنها تقنية موجودة.
الوضع مشابه في المهاجم.
أستطيع أن أقول إن تركيا لديها محركاتها الخاصة.
بالطبع ، هذه الطائرات تسحب الروبوت.
عندما في الواقع
الهاتف المحمول في Bayraktar tv2
عندما تفكر في الأمر مثل محرك اهتزاز
ثلاثة من ألف مؤشر في الطائرة
مكون من 2 في منزله ولكن كل ذلك
عندما تفكر في جيب للتكنولوجيا الأخرى
هاتفك الذي يجعلنا نذهب
المحركات والمحرك في المهاجم أكثر من ذلك بقليل
حرج لأنه يوجد محرك نفاث يوجد أيضًا ملف
كم عدد الدول التي نعمل معها و
عملنا لتطوير مقعدنا
يستمر ، ولكن كما قلت ، الأهم
النقطة المهمة هي أن هذه التكنولوجيا هي ملكنا بالكامل.
نصمم كل الداخل
أجهزة الكمبيوتر
برامج الإلكترونيات بأنفسنا
أنا حتى أقول ذلك
جسمها مصنوع من ألياف الكربون
هذه الطائرات في تركيا مع تلك الألياف
نسيج ألياف الكربون الذي يتم تصنيعه
حتى أنت ، الإنتاج المحلي ، أي تركيا
نشكر الله على هذا التحول في العشرينات الماضية
دفاع مستقل إلى حد كبير
نأمل أن تكمل الصناعة دورها
كما في بقية العالم
نعتقد أن هذا التحول إلى مجالات مدنية أخرى.
في الواقع ، إلى حد ما ، انتشر كل شيء
هذا ما حدث في جميع أنحاء العالم
انتشر في المناطق المدنية وأكبر من ذلك بكثير
واحد
التطور التكنولوجي
نحن نهدف إليه وما زال في انتظارك
خذ التدفئة ، دعنا نرى طاولة طين الهيليوم
لماذا
الاكثر خطرا
عندما تنظر إلى العالم كله
من كل من الشركات التقنية الناشئة الكبرى
هذا ما يقولون من المرآب ، صغير جدًا
واحد في ورش العمل وليس الأرض
لجميع التقنيات
من الأشياء الصغيرة
كما ترى ، فمن الواضح للعالم في العمل
عمالقة الحقول
الأشخاص الذين غيروا العالم حقًا
نقلت إلى الولاية في المناطق
لا المقتنيات ، مثل أفاسيك الشباب
بإعدادات صغيرة وكبيرة يقوم الشباب بإعدادها
سترى أن هناك شركات ناشئة
عمالقة التكنولوجيا في العالم
حتى الان
في هذه الحالة ، قصة بايكال كذلك
يمكننا أن نقول مثل هذا ، قليلًا
إذا كان أصغر شخص من الورشة من السد لكن
من رؤية كبيرة بحلم كبير
في هذا المجال ، جعلت بلدي مستقلاً تمامًا.
سأبذل قصارى جهدي في العالم مع Vision
مع رؤية ما سأفعله و
هذه قصة الدوري هذه حياته
قصة عمله آدم يبلغ من العمر عشرين سنة حدثناها
لذلك في الواقع عندما تنظر إلى هذا
لا تدع الحجم الذي تراه يخدعك.
أكبر الوظائف في أصغر الأماكن
نحن حتى أعظم قيمة هنا
إنها ليست مصانع كبيرة وكلها. مرة أخرى
لا تنخدع ، التكنولوجيا العظيمة هنا
أنت في الحرم الجامعي ولكن القيمة الأكبر
هنا وفي الواقع هنا كذلك
بالضبط هكذا كل الأعمال العظيمة
الأعمال العظيمة aknetrend أداة
هناك الباقي ، وهو الشخص الكبير الذي يمنحها الروح
الشخص الذي يقدم هذا الاعتقاد هو أهم شيء
إذن هذه هي النقطة
العظمة هي إبداعك من هذا المصنع
تخيل كل هذه المصانع
يتم إجراء هذا الاختبار أيضًا عند إنتاج لونين من السود.
يمكنك شراء ثلاثة منهم
يمكنك أيضًا شراء ما تنتجه ، لكن هذا هو الحال
تدريب العقول على القيام بالعمل و
إن تكوين الروح أصعب بكثير ، وهو أصعب بكثير.
غرفتك المرهقة أكثر صعوبة
و kadris عملية أكثر أهمية بكثير
دعنا نحصل على هذا الذي تبحث عنه دعونا نفضل fy11 ha
شكرا لك
واحد أخير
عابرة
تركيا هي أمي إنه فيلم لفائف
يقوم ستيف جوبز بتصفية الهواء في المزرعة
هنا فوس
من تركيا
في العالم
النظر في هذه المنطقة
نرى أمريكا الصين إسرائيل
نرى أن هناك البريد وفي تركيا
الأولى في فئتها في العالم لـ
أفضل شخص
من حروبنا لكنها أكبر
هناك منصات ، وهنا حرب بدون طيار
نحن نعمل عليه مثل طائرته الآن
تركيا ، الحمد لله ، في فئتها.
الافضل في العالم
حتى تمكنت من صنع منصات
بفضل المنصة
تسعون بالمائة من مجمل عائدات بايكار
يقترب من الصادرات ، وهذا
التصدير هو أيضا تطويرنا حديثا
لكل من التقنيات والمنصات
هذا ما نهدف إليه في المستقبل نحن نطير
10 سنوات لـ Cezeri التي نسميها سيارة.
التي أعددناها في اليوم التالي
عظيم للطائرات بدون طيار جنبا إلى جنب
نحن نقدم فرصة الموارد
من اليوم الأول بمواردنا الخاصة
لقد طورت هذه التكنولوجيا من حجم صغير
كما قلت بدءًا من هنا
الوقت الكبير يمكن أن يكون حجرًا لأنه
توقف عندما تكبر
يحدث شيء مهم حقًا هو مستقبلك
غير قادر على القيام بعملهم
أنت تعلم أن هذا هو السبب في أنه غير العالم
في الواقع ، ملف
سوف يكتبون القصص
متعلق بالسؤال الذي طرحته للتو.
لذلك في بعض الأحيان أريد أن أؤكد أكثر
حجمنا هو أكبر ميزة لك
قد لا تكون في تركيا على سبيل المثال
أنتجت للأسف في مجال الطيران
كان لديه مغامرة في الماضي
نوري دميراغ لار فيسير بيردز
لقد قاموا ببعض الأعمال ولكن للأسف الجبهة
قطع وتركيا مهمة في مجال الطيران.
لم يكن له مكان ولكن على الأقل
بدءا من
هذه هي الطريقة التي نأتي بها بسرعة وندخل هذا الفضاء
العالم في بعض الطائرات من الدرجة في هذا المجال
تخيل حتى توفير القيادة
وهي منصة قريبة من هذا في أوروبا
ولا حتى في الدول الأوروبية في الوقت الحالي
حروبنا البشرية
يتم بيعها وتصديرها فماذا عني
فقط
ليس الكبار ، ولا سيما الصغار
قصص كبيرة ومبادرات صغيرة هنا
أن المبادرات الحماسية وقوة العقل
أكبر دخول في العالم
أعتقد أنك ستكتب القصص
كل شبابنا يشاهدون من هنا أيضًا
قادرة على تحقيق أكبر
ليقولها كإخوة
أريد أن أعرف حتى لام في تلك اللحظة
سنضيف إلى نجاح شباب الترك
قالت أخت الشبك إنني سأجد
يأتي الشباب ، هذا هو العلم
manhem ولكن القليل من الحمار الوحشي عن ظهر قلب
هيا ، فيل الحياة هو النفس
اسعار وشبابيك فيلم ميني لسوريا
إذا كنت إنسانًا ، فأنت تبحث عن ذلك وتجادل فيه.
انتظر ، أعتقد أنني حصلت عليه ، أليس كذلك؟
بالطبع نحن الآن في حروب بشرية
نحن تركيا نحترم 16 دولة و 16 دولة
تخضع لعلاقة تصدير تجارية
كل منهم
هذا هو أكثر أهمية من الآخر
لا استطيع ان اقول
تركيا منحتها الدولة بالكامل
الأذونات الممنوحة من قبل دولة الجمهورية
ضمن نطاق هذا التصدير
إنه يحدث ولكن بالنسبة لنا
أصدقاء تركيا وحلفاؤها بالطبع
تعمل كل خيط واحد كل وذاك
استقلال بلادنا
لتطوير
فخر لنا وشرف عظيم لنا
أستطيع أن أقول إن هذا هو المصدر أيضًا
ردود فعل إضافية نحصل عليها
شكرا لرؤية أوجه القصور هناك
الأفضل على الإطلاق
لدينا الفرصة لتطوير
لكن حتى الحاخام فاراكاسي أنا بثمن
دوغان هاس مان ريمكس آلي من ساقه
في إسمنت سوري حسيب فيل شهر
أقسم
رأي FIFA الأزرق لا يتم أخذ كذبة
حفظ الرمل في عمر أكدل طبعا أذربيجان
في داخلنا
أمة واحدة ، دولتان
نقول اخواننا هناك
ولا سيما قضية كاراباخ بالنسبة لنا
من شبابنا
كان مجرد جرح ينزف بداخلنا
كمهندس
تطوير هذه التقنيات و
هذا هو سبب الفوز
طبعا انتصار التكنولوجيا لله
النصر المطلق دائما الله تيلة ولكن
أننا نبذل مثل هذا الجهد وذاك
مجهودك
منتصرا و
فقدت المحتلة
لقد استعدنا أرضنا
في المهندسين
أعظم شرف و
أستطيع أن أقول إنه شرف بهذا المعنى ، لكننا نحن
في كل جهودنا
نواصل عملنا
نحن نفعل
عز ادناك قطع احمد عن الغاز والبردال
10 كلمات سيلفستر
حيوان بالطبع
حسنًا
المحاضر الذي ذكرته
إنه يشبه في بعض الأماكن
تدريس قمت بدورة فيه
أنا موظف ، تم الإعلان عن ذلك كوظيفة ولكن
أسميها لأول مرة
سمعت من الصحافة مثلك
كما أفهمها
خلال معركة كاراباخ
في مثل هذه المقابلة
هنا هو القابس الذي يستخدم تعبير سلجوق
بيرقدار لأننا نقدم التدريب
ومع ذلك ، فقد استخدم تعبيرًا كما لو أننا نخجل.
كاراباخ المحتلة لنا
بعبارة أخرى ، نسمي أمة واحدة ، دولتين.
ضياع شقيقنا الأذربيجاني
كانت أرضهم ، وكان هناك بداخلنا أيضًا.
متحدون في أذربيجان
معترف بها من قبل الأمم
إما لأنها مشغولة في العمل
الحق في الدفاع عن النفس بشكل كامل
استخدام
استعادوا هذه الأراضي وهنا أيضًا
بالطبع نحن فخورون
من صنع حياتنا كمهندسين
هذا نكرس
أدت التكنولوجيا إلى هذا النصر
لنا
إنه مصدر فخر واعتزاز كبيرين
أستطيع أن أقول بالطبع شخص ما
بلادنا المستقلة
قد يكونون غير مرتاحين للاستقلالية.
القبعة بالطبع سوف يمسك شخص ما
قد يشككون في سيادتنا ، لكن
نحن نعلم ذلك جيدًا
دفاع مستقل في عصرنا
إذا لم يكن لديك الصناعة
من الاستقلال إلى السيادة
الى جانب ذلك ، لا يمكننا التحدث عنها
بالطبع ، في جميع أنحاء العالم
ولادة التكنولوجيا
نرى أن هذه هي صناعة الدفاع
جميع الهواتف النقالة عالية التقنية التي نستخدمها
أمسك هاتفك بأجهزة الكمبيوتر
نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي
حتى وادي السيليكون الأسود
صناعة الدفاع الشهيرة
ما نراه هو البحث
في بعض الأحيان تصبح بعض التقنيات متحضرة
عالم أكبر بكثير
يمكن أن تؤثر اقتصاديا كبيرا
الناتج ينتج هذا أيضًا في تركيا
التحول في صناعة الدفاع
مع الاكتمال
إليكم رؤية التأميم كما آمل
جميع التكنولوجيا المدنية التكنولوجية الأخرى
بشكل مستقل عن طريق التطوير
مع المزدهر
حضارة كيه صوت جسدنا
إلى العالم بصوت أعلى سيدا
يقول ، من أجل أن يُسمع
قيم حضارتنا بحنان و
قيمة العدالة بصوت أعلى
آمل أن تكون ضرورية للغذاء في العالم
كما أنه سيخلق البنية التحتية ، لذلك نحن
نحن الآن فقط بلغة صناعة الدفاع
مماثلة في جميع المجالات المدنية الأخرى.
لاستكمال التحول و
بلدنا أيضا يختلف في هذه المجالات.
تكنولوجيا المبادرات المدنية
محاولاتك
مدوي في العالم
تركيا حيث قام بالتطورات
نتخيل أن هناك قوة
نواصل العمل مات
المتلقي نعم هيا
عزيزي ، هل أنت مهم ، من هو سيزري؟
أتعلم ، صحيح؟ سيزري لي على الأقل.
أولا قلتي أخ "الحاج" من المنحة نعم
الآن أخبرني أنك معلمك ، هل قلت ذلك؟
لأن معلمنا الرئيسي هو سيزري
الجزري عالم مسلم و
مؤسس الروبوتات
مؤسس علم التحكم الآلي و
إذن ما ذكرناه للتو
أكاديمية الأكاديمية من أستاذ في المؤسسة
كيف تعلمنا مؤسس العلم
هذا العلم وهب الإنسانية هدية ، نحن
لقد جئنا من مدرسته
نتبع واسم سيارتنا أيضًا
فيفا لإحياء ذكراه
نضع Cezeri مع الشعور
أصبح الحلم الآن هو الأكبر في عالم السيارات
منذ أن بدأ الإنتاج الضخم الذي نعيش فيه اليوم
حلوة للإنتاج بالجملة مع الثورة القادمة
كالثورة الصناعية الثانية
معروف ، كما تعلم ، القرن العشرين
سيارات كهربائية وذكية
السيارات القادمة إلى حياتنا
ماذا سيحدث بعد ذلك بالطائرة الذكية للسيارات
سيأتي ، لكن العالم لم يتكيف بعد مع هذه التكنولوجيا.
لذلك لم تصل إلى مستوى الإنتاج
ليست آمنة تمامًا ولا رخيصة جدًا وهنا هي
هناك العديد من التقنيات القادمة قيد التطوير
بالطبع ، ليست السيارات الطائرة ، لكن هذا يتبادر إلى الذهن.
ليس فقط سيارات الأجرة الطائرة ، طيران
يأتي ذلك في حياتنا الشحنات
من مواقف العمل في مكان ما
الطب الفوري للمصابين المحاصرين
لنقل أو إخلاء الجرحى
إلى مكانة عالية
كان يتحدث عن طائرات بدون طيار
عامل أنهم هذا كل شيء طيران
التنقل ونصف تقنية كبيرة جدًا
القادمة كموجة وموجة الغد
لذلك هذا هو يومك ، وتأثير خطوة بخطوة
نرى أنه بدأ يخرج ولكن
واحدة من أكبر الثورات في عالم السيارات
سيكون هناك واحد حتى السيارات تسير على الأرض
ستستمر لكن الطائرة ستكون على الأقل قصيرة
كل أنواع المسافات المختلفة
سيأتي معنا العديد من السيارات الطائرة
بدأنا العمل في هذا المجال من اليوم
استغرقت أول رحلة لها منذ عام ونصف.
سر ، بالطبع ، هذا حلم يمتد لعشر سنوات.
أي أننا نهدف إلى 10 سنوات من الآن.
حياة واحدة وكل ذلك في هذا المجال
نحن في الواقع نقوم بعملنا لهذه الطائرات.
التكنولوجيا التي قمنا بتطويرها وما إلى ذلك
سيتم استخدام هذا لجعل
لا تعرفوني يا حاجه رسالة شباب في
تركيا حامل Elvan teknofest Trident
متقلبة ولكنها ذات صلة بطريقة leptica plus
المباني الخاصة بي لن تكون ممكنة
ليست الأغنية الشعبية سيد يوسف
طريق
بالتاكيد نحن
مستوحاة من مغامرتنا الخاصة
نحن نعيش في طائرات بدون طيار
نضالنا في البيكار من المغامرة
الذي
لقد فهمنا ذلك من عشرين عامًا من النضال
لذلك يمكن أن يأتي الربيع مع زهرة
ليست بلادنا مستقلة تمامًا وموريفت
مثل هذه المبادرات لتكون
حلوة مبادرات مختلفة
ليس فقط في صناعة الدفاع
وفي جميع المجالات المدنية الأخرى
يجب أن تكون المبادرات
في داخل
لذلك هناك حاجة إلى تحول اجتماعي
جميع شرائح المجتمع
كيف وطنية
عندما يكون هناك تطابق نحبه جميعًا
فريقك المفضل هو بطل أوروبا
احتفل به بحماس كبير
هـ ومع ذلك ، فإن القدرة على تطوير التكنولوجيا اليوم
هذا هو العالم الذي نعيش فيه
رياح عظيمة لتحويل هذه القدرة
يأتي من خلال محو الأمية
أليست مثل البلاد
كيف يكون هذا إلى الوراء عندما تكون الأمية منخفضة؟
لكسلهم
اليوم فقط
التكنولوجيا وليس محو الأمية.
قدرتهم على التطور
إلى أي مدى هم وكيف
ميراثهم وحتى كم
الأكثر استقلالية
معلمة مهمة لهذا الغرض تركيا
تركيا ، التي نسمي فريقها t3vakfi
فريق التكنولوجيا
أنشأنا مؤسستنا ونسميها التجريب
المدارس المتوسطة والثانوية في ورش العمل
الآلاف من الشباب على مستوى
لإعطاء شبابنا تعليمًا مجانيًا
بدأنا لأننا
نحن حضارتنا إيجابية بالفعل
الحضارة التي أصبحت مؤسسة العلم ولكن 15
16 بعد القرن السابع عشر ، لدينا هذه الصدارة.
نرى أننا فقدنا هنا حرزمي
تحدثنا عن الزواج
تحدثنا عن خط الصيد.
تحدثنا عن سيسيلي ، التي أتيت منها.
أي مؤسسو العلوم الأساسية
الأشخاص الذين لديهم مثل هذه العلاقة
للأسف حضارتنا
بعد فترة من الوقت يفقد بعض و
من ناحية ، مع هذه الخسارة
لا يمكننا فعل ذلك مع فقدان الثقة بالنفس.
مثل هذه المنطقة واستقرت الثقافة و
لذلك فقط مع التحول الثقافي
القدرة الثقافية على الفوز بها مرة أخرى
لأنه يمكن أن يكون في تحول
للغرض بالطبع ابتداء من بلدنا
اتمنى للدول الشقيقة والصديقة
مؤسستنا ستواصل أنشطتها
نظرة فريق التكنولوجيا في تركيا لدينا
فريق تركيا التكنولوجي لمؤسستنا
بدأنا في تنفيذ أنشطتها في الزجاجة
أنشأنا ورش العمل التي نسميها ما فعله
أنشطة تسمى مراكز العلوم
هنا مرة أخرى أشعر بالفضول حول العلم
لمهاجمة التكنولوجيا
قمنا بتنظيم أنشطة مختلفة للشباب.
بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، هو أكثر لفتا للانتباه و
حتى يحتفل به مثل المهرجان
لا أعرف أي نوع من المهرجانات في بلدنا
لدينا ، على سبيل المثال ، مهرجان الكرز
أعطيت الجميع في تركيا ، المنتجين
يجلبون الكرز الذي يزرعونه
يظهرون ذلك من قبل
هل سيكون هناك مهرجان للتكنولوجيا؟
لم اسمع عن دبس السكر في العالم
نقوم بهذه الطريقة لأغراض تجارية.
قلنا لضمان التحول الاجتماعي
دعونا نجعل من مهرجان التكنولوجيا
مساحة طيران اسطنبول للطيران و
قمنا بتنظيم مهرجان التكنولوجيا به
التكنولوجيا في مركزها
لديهم مسابقات ، وهو اتجاه المستقبل
هناك مسابقات وكذلك معارض
التعليمية في ما يمكننا قوله
الشركات ذات المحتوى
عرض التكنولوجيا الخاصة بهم
التكنولوجيا المصنوعة في تركيا
المناطق التي يعرضونها ، وكذلك
لدينا أرضية عمل وبالطبع للتعبير عن فرحتنا
عروض جوية في جميع أنحاء العالم
أنت تعرف كل العروض الجوية
إثارة الناس
[موسيقى]
الأحداث تجري من السنة الأولى
كانت السباحة كبيرة جدًا ، نحن 100.000 50
عندما تقول أن ألف شخص فقط يأتون ، 551
استضافت الزوار ، Tek Nefes Sayın
رئيسنا رجب طيب أردوغان
كيف تأتي وتنافس في مجال التكنولوجيا
ميداليات الأبطال الأولمبيين
وهؤلاء الإخوة والأخوات الصغار
أعطوا جوائزهم طالب e BİM
تقدم إلى المسابقات في سنتين 50 ألف
3. السنة التي تجاوزناها 100 ألف
هل كانت 200 ألف في السنة ، رقماً قياسياً؟
لتكنوفست مرة واحدة في العالم حتى الآن
لقد كنت أعظم منصة مسابقة
أي مسابقات مماثلة حول العالم
لديهم منصات صغيرة تنظم ذلك ، لكن هذا
على المستوى الوطني على نطاق واسع
لا توجد منصة مع كل الحماس
يتم الاحتفال بعام technofes جديد
مثل قدوم الموسم والطقس في البلاد
أستطيع أن أقول إنه يتغير في تركيا
آمل الأجيال القادمة
عشرات الآلاف ومئات الآلاف هذا ما تراه
التكنولوجيا مثل الطائرات بدون طيار
للشركات الكبرى في جميع أنحاء العالم في كل فرع
سوف يوقعون لأننا نعرف ذلك
طفل تنفد تقنيته الوحيدة عن الموضة
ربما تأتي ونسج طائرة
برنامج الفضاء المستقبلي لبلدنا
هذا الطفل سوف تتاح له فرصة العمل.
حتى غير الأطفال يحصلون على هناك مجانًا
حتى الطفل المحروم مجاني
يمكن أن يأتي كل شيء إلى teknofest مجانًا
يتم بهذه الروح لصالح المجتمع.
نحن نفعل ذلك كحدث
نعتقد أن هذا كنا منذ 5 سنوات.
يتم حرث الحقل وآمل 5-10 سنوات
بدأت البذور فيه تنبت
بالمناسبة بلدنا مثل بايكار.
مثل بيرقدار ، عشرات ، وربما مئات
ستكون هذه محاولة من العالم
الأشياء التي ستؤثر حتى على التغيير
سيجعلوننا ندرك هذه الإمكانات
نحن نعلم ذلك في حضارتنا
نحن نعلم أنه موجود في شعبنا ، لكن هذا يكفي.
حتى يؤمنوا
دعهم يظهرون المثالية على أعلى مستوى
عسى أن يعيشوا في أرواحهم وليس أبدًا
بهذه الطريقة الصحيحة
الصالحين من الأخلاق
من المغادرة لأن كل عملك
العدل والعدل في اساس الجميع
يفعل الأخلاق يكون مستقيما نحن
أفضل جهد لدينا
سوف نظهر وبالطبع عقولنا
سنستخدم اليوم ليس سباقاتك أنا
غدا سنعمل على سباقات المستقبل
سنبذل قصارى جهدنا في سباقاتك.
الله يوفقنا لاننا نؤمن
وسنكون الأفضل في العالم
أن هناك الآلاف من الشباب مثل هؤلاء
نحن نعلم أن تركيا والعالم الإسلامي
بهذا المعنى ، أنت أيضًا في هذا البرنامج.
لإعطائي الفرصة لإعطاء هذه الرسالة
أيضا شكرا لك و Salat Hobby
انتقال الضباط ذات الصلة بالحلقة
Aha nahvel حقيقية جديدة مزدوجة ذلك
نظرت إلى Atiye Ameliye أو حتى
الجراحة والمياه الجراحية
ليلى
أليس هذا عندما يخرج؟
[موسيقى]